all right what do we know now about the
lengths that trying to went to to
disguise the true magnitude of the
original outbreak in Wuhan well some
believe at this point we should be
beyond that question that's a
distraction I think there's a lot of you
know incorrect and unfair things that
China did a lot of things right
you know at the beginning like any
country where a virus first shows up you
know they can look back and say where
they they missed some things what about
China let's discuss that and much more
with Republican senator from Utah
Michael Eason our good to have you back
with us Thank You Shannon okay so it's
fair to say in the beginning there are a
lot of things we didn't know China
didn't know maybe some things they once
they learned didn't share them with us I
mean we're all learning a lot as we go
along but here's what China's foreign
ministry spokesperson says China always
stands against disinformation campaign
we our victim rather than producer of
disinformation peddling disinformation
and recrimination are by no means
prescription for international anti
pandemic cooperation and should be
rejected by all where do we go now with
China Senator look the first thing we
have to remember with China is that this
is a totalitarian state this is a
communist dictatorship consequently I
mean sure we can trade with them from
time to time if we want to to the extent
we want to under our terms but we can't
lose sight Chinon of the fact that this
is a communist regime and and therefore
one in which you can't really
differentiate between a business
enterprise and the Chinese government
and the Chinese military this is a
three-headed monster which gato
acknowledged it as such
all right and yeah it's so many American
companies have very deep connections
operations their supply lines we know
about our pharmaceutical supply lines is
there any way that we really can
quote-unquote punish or hold China
accountable knowing how intertwined our
two economies really are well sure and
the fact that they're intertwined
doesn't mean that they always have to be
to that same extent the fact that we're
mad at them doesn't mean that we can't
have any trade with them but take the
pharmaceutical industry as one example
we've got substantial manufacturing
capacity in this country in places like
Pennsylvania New Jersey Indiana and
Puerto Rico where we could be
manufacturing more of our pharmaceutical
products than we have been we should
become less subject to the whims of this
communist dictatorship especially with
things like pharmaceutical products so
let's let's adopt policies let's adopt
changes in our tax code and our
regulatory system if we have to in order
to bring more of that manufacturing
capacity back to the United States this
is one area especially with regard to
prescription drugs or I think Americans
would voluntarily even without action by
the government voluntarily spend maybe a
little bit more say 50 to 75 cents more
per prescription if they know that it's
gonna be a secure pipeline and not one
that relies on this communist
dictatorship okay when I try to jam in
to more topics with you first of all
this idea that you all will be back on
the hill possibly trying to hammer out
another deal I know you've been very
concerned about some of what's been
passed already but with respect to the
crackdown saying we're not going to bail
out blue states the Republicans saying
that the Chicago Sun Times editorial
board says this in the midst of a fiscal
crisis that threatens to slide into a
second Great Depression his solution
being meeting Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell would be for states to
stiff creditors fire or reduce the pay
of hundreds of thousands of workers
slash health care and retirement
benefits and cut back on services to the
mentally ill the disabled and the
elderly they're calling him out on this
idea of pushing back against states
asking for financial help what do you
think look I think I disagree with every
single word uttered by the Chicago
sun-times there everything they said is
wrong every single characterization that
they've pinned on Mitch McConnell is
unfair look the effect is Shannon if you
take the top five states with the top
highest per capita unfunded pension
liabilities they amount to roughly five
times the per capita unfunded pension
liabilities of the most responsible
states we can't as a federal government
at the time when we've already
appropriated and spent 150 billion
dollars helping States specifically deal
with the bovid 19 epidemic we can't in
that same moment fix another problem
that's been years in fact decades in the
making
as a result of decade
of mismanagement by Democratic liberal
progressive regimes in various states
we can't suddenly change that and
pretend that this is all somehow
necessitated by cope at 19 much as the
Chicago sun-times might want to pretend
otherwise they're wrong okay super quick
the speaker's idea that there possibly
is a way for the federal government or
there should be to guarantee a minimum
income to some Americans go if we want
to become a Western European style style
socialized democracy then that is the
approach we should pay in fact is
Shannon that hurts poor and middle class
people and the fact is that that runs
contrary to everything we believe about
the limited role of government and about
the ability that individual citizens
need to have to achieve upward economic
mobility if you want a stagnant economy
and what in which poor and middle-class
Americans are locked in place and have
artificial barriers put in their way by
government and that's what you should do
otherwise we should stick to free
markets Nancy Pelosi knows better and
she ought to be ashamed of herself for
suggesting otherwise all right well you
all will be back here in a matter of
days in DC will see you then if not
before Senator Mike Lee thank you thank
you